les yvelinois propriétaires de leur
logement s'en rappellent encore plus 66%
c'est l'augmentation de la taxe foncière
voter en 2016 par l'assemblée
départementale
une augmentation une nouvelle fois au
coeur des débats pour cette dernière
séance de l'année et qui a permis selon
l'exécutif de faire face à la chute des
moyens alloués par l'état - 33 millions
d'euros encore l'an prochain quand on
augmente les impôts c'est pas pour payer
des voitures de sanction il y en a pas
c'est pas pour payer des palais ici
c'est un palais qui a été construit au
19e siècle et tous les autres
départements se sont construit des
hôtels du département pas de nous on a
toujours été très économe dans le
département des yvelines on veut
conserver cela pour laisser aux
yvelinois l'argent maîtrise des dépenses
de fonctionnement poursuite de
l'investissement les élus se sont vu
présenter les orientations budgétaires
pour 2010 est dans une assemblée son
opposition politique
certains se montrent tout de même
critique quant aux choix réalisés nous
devons revenir à ce qui est vraiment
l'adn du département des yvelines
on a toujours recherché la modération
fiscale à la fois pour préserver le
pouvoir d'achat des yvelines war et pour
la compétitivité des entreprises de
notre territoire et je regrette que
on se soit montrée aussi brutale en
matière fiscale le vote du budget
primitif 2010 7 est prévue pour le 27
janvier prochain